as of yesterday april 19th every
american is now
eligible for the coronavirus vaccine
within the age ranges approved for
each vaccine that's 18 plus for the
moderna vaccine
18 plus for the johnson johnson vaccine
paused but expected to be resumed
as soon as friday possibly and 16 plus
for the pfizer vaccine this was
originally going to sort of be sometime
this summer for full eligibility then
joe biden announced it would be may 1st
then joe biden announced in march that
it would be pushed up to april 19th
and we are there and it really couldn't
come at a better time
for two different reasons at least two
different reasons
first of all in some states demand is
slackening for vaccines uh
states with more republicans 43 percent
of whom do not plan to get this vaccine
have more vaccine hesitancy and so
they are starting to see in some sense
more supply than demand
and so opening vaccination eligibility
to more people
will hopefully boost vaccination numbers
and keep going with vaccinating you know
three to four million people per day
secondly because of the johnson and
johnson vaccine
being paused vaccine numbers have been
slightly declining
and we want to keep things going the u.s
is still averaging a very strong
3.19 just short of 3.2 million vaccine
doses per day
and we want to grow that number and
thirdly expanding eligibility to all
adults and then 16 plus for the pfizer
vaccine is important because we are
really in a race against variants
which some countries are winning and we
want to get there too
there is a lot of doom and gloom about
the variance the variance nothing
nothing works it's just a disaster
if you look at cases and deaths in the
uk
the source of the british b117 variant
cases are now down to 96 per day that's
not
96 per capita it's just 96 cases per day
um that is down i'm sorry the cases are
down
96 from their peak in mid-january
if you look at israel another highly
vaccinated country
cases are now down more than 98
and uh these are countries with many
variants when you look at a country like
israel and in israel it's been all
vaccination
they are around 56 fully vaccinated
around 50 cases started to fall off a
cliff and go close to zero
in the uk the vaccination has been more
modest
but the guidelines have been significant
and the uk is actually only 15 fully
vaccinated but
at 50 partial and that is absolutely
huge as well
in the us right now we are at 25
fully vaccinated and 40 partially as of
a few days ago
numbers probably a little bit better by
now based on that
we are probably if we can keep this
going 30 or so days
remember two weeks ago we said it was
probably 35 to 45 days we are probably
about 30 days
from significant improvements here but
people need to get vaccinated and now
with full eligibility hopefully that
will happen
my 17 year old sister got her first dose
this week just about everybody i know
has had one dose already
things are moving in the right direction
now sadly
one poll says it's 20 another says it's
30 percent
at least 20 percent of the country
simply doesn't want the vaccine and most
of them are republicans
43 of republicans as we talked about
last week and i mentioned earlier
do not want the vaccine and that's a
major problem now
over time with more and more colleges
saying if you want to come back to
campus you need a vaccine
more and more venues and businesses and
even foreign countries saying
if tourists want to come here they will
need to be vaccinated
hopefully these numbers will improve
just get your vaccine
don't lose sleep over the mega clowns
for now 80 percent
is still enough for herd immunity let's
do what we can
now and then deal with the people
who selfishly will not get vaccinated
due to ignorance due to disdain due to
political misunderstandings due to
conspiracism
whatever the case may be let's keep
going we have
potentially authorization coming from
multiple vaccines
for the 12 to 15 and 12 to 17 age ranges
for the respective vaccines tests being
done
uh to look at expanding it even further
so all of this is going in the right
direction for now i mean listen i've
said before i i get it it's frustrating
to see people
who could get vaccinated and who say i'm
not going to and they could spread it
and then they could give it to somebody
who's not able to get the vaccine
or who is in the five percent that by by
you know odds don't develop immunity
and then some of those people will die
like i get it but let's focus on what we
can control
and now that we have full vaccine
eligibility you can get vaccinated
that's the most important thing and
we're going to continue following what
happens with jnj
and what happens with vaccine hesitancy
and the whole thing
yesterday we saw closing statements in
the derek chauvin trial
in minnesota this is the trial of the
police officer who killed george floyd
in the case that last summer catalyzed
nationwide protests we may soon know the
verdict
but in the meantime it's even
conceivable by the time we publish this
clip we will know the verdict although
it doesn't seem to be moving
quite so quickly but in the meantime
what we know for sure
is that derek chovan's lawyer eric
nelson gave a completely
deranged and delusional closing
statement that in a sense
actually felt trumpian in the way that
trump pushed the presidency to new lows
eric nelson pushed legal defense to new
lows
with this ridiculous closing statement
here is eric nelson saying
that there are elements of criminal
trials that are like
chocolate chip cookies yes take a look
the criminal case is kind of like baking
chocolate chip cookies
you have to have the necessary
ingredients you've got to have
flour and sugar and butter and chocolate
chips
whatever else goes into those chocolate
chip cookies
if you have all of the ingredients you
can make chocolate chip cookies
but if you're missing any one single
ingredient
you can't make chocolate chip cookies
it's a simple kind of
analogy but the criminal law works the
same way
we say the ingre we call the ingredients
the elements
the state has the burden of proving each
and every element beyond a reasonable
doubt not only is it bizarre it's also
wrong like you can make chocolate chip
cookies often without any one ingredient
you might think well i definitely need
flour
no you can use flour alternatives well
okay but i need eggs
no you can use applesauce as an
emulsifier instead of eggs okay but
butter i definitely need
no you can replace butter with any
number of lubricating elements oils
of different kinds it's just a very dumb
analogy but sadly
it may be one that is fine-tuned to what
eric nelson perceives to be the level of
the jury we just don't know
that's the scary part this may actually
work i've talked before about my jury
duty experience on an assault case
and the most infuriating part
was nobody i would want to say nobody
almost no one in the jury room even
understood what it was we were
adjudicating it was a question of
was a physical altercation self-defense
by the accused and by self-defense we
don't mean
uh you know backyard bar rules of what
constitutes self-defense we were
supposed to adjudicate this case on the
basis of
the judge's instructions as to what
legally self-defense is
did it meet the required legal elements
for self-defense
and the conversation in the jury room
among everybody other than myself and
one other juror
was a colloquial discussion of now come
on this was self-defense well but hold
on a second
at the time i lived in massachusetts
what is massachusetts law about a right
to retreat
what anyway the point was on something
that simple two-thirds of the jurors
didn't even understand the law
meant to be adjudicated i'm not hugely
optimistic
uh about any particular jury i know
nothing about the derek chauvin case
jury but based on my experience i i'm
skeptical here's another portion of the
closing where eric nelson says
if you were talking you were breathing
therefore since george floyd was saying
i can't breathe
it means his breathing is fine which has
already been debunked by dr martin tobin
a pulmonologist who testified
during the case take a look it's true if
you are talking you are breathing
doesn't mean effectively and dr tobin
described
how even medical doctors have
problems sometimes assessing the
legitimacy of a patient's needs
relevant to their respiratory processes
because they're saying i can't breathe
and some doctors confuse it for just
anxiety or this
or that so if medical doctors make these
mistakes
dr tobin told you it provides a false
sense of security
right lieutenant mercil told you that
that is what is said
among police officers he's the trainer
so how many times do we hear an officer
say
based on his training and experience if
you can breathe
you can talk if you can talk you can
breathe
too and then nelson goes directly from
this
into the claim that very often people in
custody will
fake a medical emergency to avoid going
to prison now this seems particularly
bogus since george floyd
really did die is the argument that
because other people have faked medical
emergencies
derek chovin did nothing wrong in his
handling of floyd
i think that's what he's trying to imply
at least take a look at this video
a reasonable police officer will take
into consideration
again his training his experience
right lieutenant marcel talked about and
many
people talked about many of the officers
talked about how
it is not uncommon for suspects
to feign or pretend to have
a medical emergency to avoid being
arrested
unfortunately that is the reality nobody
likes to get arrested and reasonable
police officers know that
you know these hypotheticals for me
aren't doing much
but it's possible that they're doing
something for the jury we just don't
know yet and then lastly here's derek
shovin's attorney eric nelson saying
listen derek chauvin could have kicked
george floyd
he could have punched george floyd he
could have elbowed george floyd
but he didn't almost like the argument
is
he deserves an award because he didn't
kill
and elbow george floyd he merely killed
him
and i guess that's to be looked up to
take a look
officer chauvin made a decision not to
use higher levels of force
when he would have been authorized to do
that including punches
kicks elbows right all of these
tools were available to officer children
that is not an intent to purposefully
use unlawful force all right and then
actually the very last one
here is eric nelson saying listen george
floyd being put
face down that can't be a problem
because
people do really nice things face down
sometimes people sleep face down
sometimes people sun tan face down so
therefore being face down can't possibly
be
part of this case we've heard a lot
about the prone position
consider just the basic prone position
people sleep in the problem position
people sun tan in the prone position
people get massages in the prone
position the prone position in and of
itself is not
an inherently dangerous act it is not an
inherently dangerous act so this is the
idea and this is a common legal strategy
take each piece and say that's not a
problem
prone position isn't a problem by itself
knee to the neck isn't a problem by
itself a plus you know derek chauvin
didn't punch george floyd he didn't
elbow george floyd but the point is
all together it is a big deal everything
together
killed george floyd period and that is
what is ultimately
being adjudicated here i really couldn't
tell you how this is going to end up
we're left to wait
there is tension in minnesota in advance
of the verdict concerns about unrest and
to be clear
derek chauvin is innocent until proven
guilty
don't send me the voicemails about oh
david you're looking to hang this guy
first of all i'm against the death
penalty i'm not looking to hang anybody
and of course derek chovin is innocent
until proven guilty
he deserves competent defense counsel
like everyone else full stop there's no
qualifier
the closing statement just happens to be
nonsense
but that doesn't mean it will not work
maybe eric nelson is a [ __ ] but maybe
eric nelson
accurately has assessed what will appeal
to this
jury and that may be the chocolate chip
cookie analogy
we will know when we get the verdict let
me know what you expect you can find me
on twitter
deepakman the number one funding source
for the david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
remember that the david pakman show
depends on the support of viewers
and listeners just like you you might
think they're different but they're not
they're really just like you you can
sign up at joinpakman.com you can use a
coupon code for a discount if you prefer
that code is better 21. donald trump
resurfaced yesterday
on fox news's sean hannity program and
told many of the same
corrosive lies that he's been telling
about the 2020 election since november
and why wouldn't we expect that trump
was still telling the same corrosive and
debunked lies about the 2016 election as
recently as january
if trump still hasn't accepted the
results of the 2016 election why on
earth would we expect him to accept the
results of the 2020 election
everything about this interview is
hilarious here is sean hannity
introducing it
sean hannity framing this as a major
exclusive but if you're watching you
will see
trump doesn't even seem pleased to be
sitting for this interview so tonight
for the hour
we welcome the 45th president of the
united states
donald trump mr president good to see
you thanks for joining us well thank you
very much john all right
okay so now they get into what we could
call the substance although there wasn't
very much substance
and here trump jumps right into provable
debunkable easily disprovable lies
that in presidential re-elections
presidents tend to get fewer votes in
their re-election than in their first
election it's just not true
we're going to look at the numbers but
watch trump use the lie
to somehow i guess continue making the
case that joe biden
didn't really win many other things the
big thing is taxes low taxes
taxes speak you're gonna have the
biggest tax increase you've ever seen
pro-life second amendment so many
different things
now i i hate to cut in already the tax
increase joe biden is looking at
would not be the biggest in history
trump did barely a thing on abortion
trump did nothing on the second
amendment okay let's
go to the core of it though that
look we got 75 million votes it's more
than any sitting president in history by
far
the word was if we got 65 to 66 you know
we got 63 the first time in one if you
got 65 to 66 there was no way you lost
we got more votes
we got 12 million more votes than we got
and it's never happened to another
president i don't know if you know sean
usually in a second term a president
gets less votes
i got 12 million more it's the biggest
that's ever happened in history from 63
to 75
never happened before and all of these
things are good these are popular things
but more important than popular they're
great things for this country
they're going to rip apart your second
amendment now first of all it is
fewer votes not less votes mr president
but let's not
start the grammar policing i know he
only went to wharton
but what trump says is not true trump
says presidents
typically get fewer votes in their
reelections
check out the numbers obama did get
fewer votes he lost 4 million votes from
2008 to 2012
but george w bush gained 12 million
votes in his re-election
bill clinton gained 3 million votes
ronald reagan gained 11 million votes
richard nixon gained 16 million votes
and dwight d
eisenhower gained a million votes so
really
other than barack obama you have to go
back to world war
ii for a president whose votes declined
after their first term
and it's kind of a weird example it's an
exception to the rule it's fdr who had
four terms and whose presidency
in so many ways was the exception to the
rule maybe what trump means is
obama got fewer votes in the second term
and we know trump
is obsessed with barack obama maybe
that's all that this is really about but
an easily disprovable
lie from donald trump check out this
suck-up
question from sean hannity it's not even
really a question
it's like a gushing statement of praise
the likes of which you'd expect from
north korean television
sort of like a mr president can you
confirm how hard you're working
right so i know a lot of people that are
around you every day
this is what they're all telling me
you're working as hard as you did when
you were in the white house
except you play a little golf more that
you you're keeping an
insane schedule seven days a week
you really don't stop well we're seeing
a lot of people we're seeing a lot of
good republicans and a lot of good
americans in some cases great americans
and hannity is doing the equivalent of
kim jong-un bold for the first time
today and he bowled the 300
he also turned water into wine this
apparently
counts as an interview on fox news now i
told you yesterday that the treasury
department put out a report confirming
coordination between donald trump's 2016
campaign chairman
paul manafort and a russian intelligence
officer constancine kilimnik
the topic of russia came up and trump
says
something completely unintelligible but
he does do the sir routine where he
claims someone came to me and they said
sir take a look at this you did run and
did win
what would you do differently um
when i came in we were hit with phony
russia-russia-russia investigations it
was a total phony deal
that was three years of your presidency
i've been i've been
fighting off investigations for five
years i mean really
since the almost the day that we came
down and they were corrupt
democrat inspired i still have it they
were democrat-inspired
investigations russia i remember
sean and i don't have too much time i
guess with you but a story i think it's
interesting i haven't told it before
during the campaign in 2016 i'd be asked
like by one of our aides
sir do you have anything to do with
russia
i said no no that would be it then
a month later somebody would say what do
you know about russia
i said no what i don't know what you're
talking about okay i wouldn't think of
it then after three or four or five
times people would say
do anything about russia i kept saying
after three or four times i said what's
going on with russia
they created a phony deal it was paid
for by hillary
crook and hillary clinton they made a
phony russian disinformation document
oh and they used it to spy on you as a
candidate correct
your transition team and while you were
president
it says at the top of fisa warrant
verified
it was unverifiable and they knew it 17
times
they knew it right from the get-go i
don't know what either of them
are talking about but they seem to be
kind of playing off of each other and
winding each other up here's a few more
seconds
from this portion of the interview they
knew they were worn beforehand
and they knew it certainly from
christopher steele and the sub source by
january total fraud
and you know what it did it hurt any
possibility
of dealing with russia we could have we
could have had a good
look they'll say oh he loves russia
getting along with
russia is a good thing not a bad thing
getting along with china is a good thing
the problem with
now when trump was asked whether he will
run again this just like
he can't answer any question normally he
said that
from a legal standpoint he doesn't
really want to talk about that
i i say this i i am looking at it very
seriously
beyond seriously uh from a legal
standpoint i don't want to really talk
about it yet
it's a little too if you did run what
does that even mean from a legal
standpoint like part of me thinks it has
to do with trump wanting to use
donations as a slush fund for his
personal expenses
i don't know why my mind goes to that
but like what could he even mean from a
legal standpoint and then trump was also
asked about republican
vaccine hesitancy and trump said
he doesn't really know why republicans
are hesitant to take the vaccine for
kovid take a look
you know they all want me to do a
commercial because a lot of our people
don't want to take vaccine you know i
don't know what that is exactly
republican
i don't know what it is you encourage
people to get i encourage them to take
it i do
but they want me to make a video did you
get it they went yes i did they
i had it and i took it okay you got both
because i believe
so here's here's the thing they want me
to do a commercial trump can't imagine
why republicans wouldn't be getting the
vaccine
because for a year trump said this
wasn't serious if something's not
serious why would anybody need a vaccine
that's why there's so much vaccine
hesitancy so
just a completely bizarre interview
and unclear what the point of it is i
guess sean hannity wants ratings
and trump wants attention like maybe
it's that simple and we don't need to
analyze the motivations more deeply but
expect
much more of this if donald trump's q
and
on congressional allies get reelected in
2022
trump will be reinvigorated you're going
to see this much more regularly
and it may be what gets donald trump to
run in 2024 as we've talked about before
so
very important that we ensure trump
doesn't get his
people you know marjorie taylor greene
and lauren bobert madison kothorne the
jim jordan yeah whoever
anybody that can be removed in 2022 will
make it
less likely that trump even runs in
2024.
let's talk about virtue signaling the
right
says that they are against so-called
virtue signaling now
virtue signaling is when you publicly
express an opinion
to try to signal that you are morally on
the right side of something or to signal
that your character is to be respected
um and republican arizona governor doug
ducey
is doing exactly this he has issued an
executive order banning
so-called vaccine passports of which
there are none
in arizona nor were any coming as
described by his executive order
first question what is a vaccine
passport well the executive order would
ban
state and local government in arizona
from requiring
arizonans to provide
proof of covet vaccination either to go
into some kind of government building or
to receive
something he tweeted about it saying
quote i've issued an executive order
banning vaccine passports and preventing
state and local governments
from requiring arizonans to provide
their covit 19 vaccination status
to receive service or enter an area
do you see going on to tweet that quote
the residents of our state should not be
required by the government to share
their private medical information
more on that later while we strongly
recommend all arizonans get the vaccine
it's not mandated in our state and it
never will be
now the logical question would be was
the state of arizona about to mandate
people need to get vaccinated
was the state of arizona or were
municipalities
about to say you need a vaccine in order
to go to this government building or
that or
no no nobody this was never going to
happen
so first of all this executive order is
focused on something which wasn't
actually going to be taking place
now uh uh second question is
does this actually apply to those who
might
require a vaccination like a school
or a business it does not it it would
not prevent that if the phoenix sun's
nba team
says you know what at some point once
you know maybe by
next next season to come to our games
you're going to need to
provide proof of vaccination this
executive order does nothing to stop
that
the phoenix suns could legally do that
if they want to do it
schools can require vaccinations schools
have required vaccinations for decades
in arizona just for different vaccines
and so not only is this virtue signaling
trash executive order meant to stop
something which
was not going to happen which is
mandatory vaccination
per arizona or governments
municipalities requiring the vaccine or
requiring it to do something that was
never going to happen
this is going to create anti-vaxxers
who will have heard of this and then
they will go
to a business or their kid will need a
vaccine to go to school and they will
show up and film themselves saying
ducey passed the law against this and of
course he didn't
the executive order is about what
government
will or won't do with regard to
vaccination it has nothing to do with
businesses it has nothing to do with
schools
so uh it's it's it's a combination
of pointless virtue signaling with
the addition of creating more problems
for schools and businesses
who are able to require a coronavirus
vaccination now a related topic
in that second tweet ducey said
residents of our state should not be
required by the government
to share their private medical
information
now is he on the same page with that
claim when it comes to
which bathroom a trans person wants to
use
or does he want it to be forced that
they need to provide proof of their
biological sex at birth is he on the
same page when it comes to women
and abortion or does the phrase
residents of our state should not be
required by the government to share
private medical information
only apply to covet vaccination
requirements
this guy is pathetic one of the worst of
the worst one of the worst handlings
in the country of the coronavirus
pandemic and now
the executive order which doesn't
actually deal with what people think it
deals with
and deals only with something that was
never going to happen
we're going to have more coverage of a
so-called
uh vaccine mandate conspiracism
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
and if you want to see one of our dutch
viewers yesterday in a supermarket
saw an advertisement for beer and it
looked like i was on the advertisement
it's actually really strange i posted it
to my instagram you can find me
at david.pacman
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
show great perks and benefits as well
read about him
it's my pleasure to welcome to the
program today joseph westfall who's a
senior fellow at the wharton leadership
program at the university of
pennsylvania also former u.s ambassador
to saudi arabia
i really appreciate your time today yeah
david glad to be with you and by the way
i'm a professor at the lottery institute
at wharton
okay uh an important uh important detail
um we get credit for that so when it
comes to you know we've talked for a
long time about the the us
relationship with saudi arabia and i
think that there's sometimes a simple
uh understanding which is there's
there's a goal for shared stability in
the region
often in connection with with oil prices
and the oil industry
is it quite that simple or or how would
you explain
the history of the relationship no i
think it's
it's a lot more complicated than that
and uh
you know the the one thing you have to
remember about
saudi arabia is that u.s public opinion
that is the average
american uh in gallup polls at the
gallup polls from the 1930s to today to
the latest polls
see saudi arabia in
unfavorable terms a majority of
americans think of saudi arabia in
unfavorable
ways yes and that reflects back to the
attitude that the members of congress
then have to have because they get
pressure from constituents
some of that is because there's no
knowledge saudi arabia was closed
until recently to the world so americans
haven't traveled there they haven't seen
the country they haven't visited
although many saudis have come to the
united states uh
to study and to work here so i think
that's
that lack of knowledge and that
unfavorable rating play a big role the
other thing
is of course that it is the birthplace
of islam
so you know you cannot ignore a country
that
you know hosts millions of people every
year
for religious services and it has the
kind of influence that they have around
the world
and have had for for a long time um
in addition to the fact that the region
were
not just for oil but for trade
and for also for uh big
nation powerful nations china russia
and others uh has become a a very
important region where
we're all competing over the last
i don't know how many years i mean we
can we can talk about the last five
years but it's really
sort of been been seeded earlier than
that
there has been much made publicly of
what seems to be a kind of
liberalization in some sense in saudi
arabia
arguably at least to some degree because
of the
direction that muhammad bin salman wants
to see the country go
but at the same time while publicly you
know we're hearing about
women can now drive and some of these
other things we know about
uh you know the sequestering of dozens
of of officials in a hotel in order to
interrogate and in some time sometimes
make threats and even much much worse
so as from a diplomatic perspective
uh when one thing is happening publicly
and yet very different things are
happening privately
what are the conversations like between
american diplomats and the leaders of
the country do they
do they talk about what's happening
behind the scenes as much as they talk
about what's happening publicly
well it depends on which diplomats
you're talking about
okay and that's really really good
question because diplomacy really
changed dramatically
after the obama administration so
when when i left in 2017 at the
in january at the end of the obama
administration
none of the things you pointed out had
happened
um muhammad binayaf was still the crown
prince
i had excellent meetings with him the
king
and muhammad bin salman upon leaving
we had had a great relationship we
worked on everything from
their economic transformation plan which
mbs had put forth
we worked on security issues with
muhammad pinayav
we had a great relationship um extensive
relationship trying to deal with all the
regional issues in syria
iraq and of course yemen we were
fully fully engaged as an embassy
in almost every aspect of the
relationship or every aspect of
of their uh economy education
energy you name it transportation etc
we were involved when i left in 2017
president trump did not appoint an
ambassador for two years
right and so the only diplomacy that was
going on
was between pompeo
secretary pompeo who would occasionally
travel there and
uh kushner
so so there wasn't the embassy was not
empowered to work
any of these issues and didn't have
access
and of course after i left about a month
or two after i left
mbs um was able to get his father to
compose mbn muhammad bin nayef
right as crown prince and he was named
the crown prince
and then all the things that you
mentioned started to happen
when so i think to answer your question
briefly and let me give you a chance to
add some more diplomacy is critical but
you've got to be engaged
holistically now when you were there
certainly you were aware and there was
this history of the public executions
and so on and so forth does that
get swept under the rug during
diplomatic conversations about for
example
yemen or is that present in the room
it's
it's it did not get swept under by us
from the president from president obama
to the secretary of state kerry to
myself
and i'll just choose myself as an
example
uh some ambassadors in some countries
germany switzerland
sweden others would publicly
criticize and publicly
um uh you know
be very negative about some of these
practices early on when i first got
there
uh i chose a different method i chose
the the idea that we needed to
to help them make the right decisions
but not going public with them in order
to have access and confidence that
from them in us that we weren't going to
you know
so i had the conversations with the king
with the crown prince with the deputy
crown prince about
lashings about beheadings
about ex-security executions public
executions
about the role of the matawa the
religious police
uh who were increasingly becoming a real
uh
real problem uh for them as and
especially for everybody else
and i was afraid that they were gonna
start um
perhaps at some point have attacking our
foreign diplomats
so i was very straight with them that we
weren't going to tolerate any of this
stuff it had to change and it had to
change
because our relationship was so
important
now how do they react i mean do they do
they write it off as well you know that
we just do things differently here than
you do in the united states or do they
are they aware of how those practices
are seen around the world
yes yes absolutely they especially
uh mb mbs uh
is was then very keen on knowing
uh what foreign press was saying about
saudi arabia
about him about their practices so they
were very well aware of that and very
well aware that
that our ability to uh
support his plans for the economy
for transformation for modernizing the
country
depended on eliminating those those
ancient practices that that he didn't
agree with
right and were tolerated because
it was still a very conservative element
within saudi arabia's people
who you know i don't know if they
demanded that but they expected that
so when i went to talk to them about it
um
uh they got it and they took action
and they eliminated all those things my
tower went back to the
to the uh to their precincts uh the
the the lashings were terminated
and the president was saying the same
thing in meetings with the king
whenever you come he he did four trips
to saudi arabia
i was present at three of them one was
before i became ambassador
now from much of what i've read it's
unclear
well i'll put it a different way from
what i've read
it's not clear to me whether the reasons
that mohammed bin salman
is taking these positions of you know
the the reforms that you talked about
and that i talked about if it's because
this is really what he believes
or rather it's because they seem to
recognize
that the oil industry may not be
the best place to be solely focused in
the future
there's this idea of diversifying the
saudi sovereign wealth fund
they need to be playing nice with london
and new york and so on and so forth and
that it's really
you know just just more of a strategic
and financial decision like what makes
you think that
mohammed bin salman really thinks these
aren't good practices
well you know when he would again when i
was ambassador
um he took some trips to the united
states
yeah in those trips he met with
everybody he went to california
he met with you know the the tech people
he met with facebook people he made with
bloomberg
uh he he met with dozens of people
uh across the board i got him uh i
wanted them to do
their their big um when their big
investment
in uh through the um their ip
ipo through the new york stock exchange
right
at the new york stock exchange and
and you know it was clear that he was
trying to build
support for his economic transformation
plan
and he wanted the united states involved
he wanted the united states engaged
president obama actually met with him
and had him over at the white house for
a meeting
uh so things were i thought things were
going very well
and you thought it was a genuine desire
to reform not just a financial incentive
no i'm the best it was you know the way
the way i started with him was
when i first got there uh the king
salman was the crown prince that's right
right
it was abdullah who was also a great guy
and i really enjoyed
working with him but muhammad uh excuse
me king salman was the crown prince and
he's the one that i principally worked
with because he was the
sort of the prime minister and
i noticed his son sitting in a couple of
meetings
far off in the corner not participating
and so
i asked for a meeting with him and we
met
and from that first meeting where we
just got to know each other
um i realized two things one
this this young man is someday going to
be the king of saudi arabia
number one number two he because he's
ambitious
and and he has always been interested
in the polit economic development of his
country from the time he was a young man
how do i know that because i did some
background work on him
so i saw it his his other brothers
were not necessarily of the same vein
but he was and that's why his father
loved him so much because his father was
a consummate politician and his son
was like him and so we developed a great
friendship
and the friendship was you know tell
each other the truth i will tell you
exactly what i think
i represent the president and my country
and i will tell you exactly what i think
and i expect you not to be polite back
if you don't agree with me if you're not
going to do what i ask you to do
then just tell me and you will negotiate
further
and that's the way we work for for the
three years i was there
in the sort of limited time we have left
the jamal khashoggi
murder um i'm curious your thoughts
uh on how the trump administration
responded to that initially donald trump
kind of saying
i don't know i just spoke to the king
and it they say they weren't involved
i believe him i don't know seems seems
pretty reasonable and then of course
the more we learned about it the more we
learned about how
at the very close to the very top if not
at the very top
they seem to have known exactly what was
going on how do you think that was
handled by the trump administration
i don't think it was handled well at all
and i think that that in some ways
they should have done to some extent
what president biden is doing now
saying you know we're not gonna we're
not gonna cut we don't we can't prove
without a without a without any doubt
that he ordered this um he has publicly
said he didn't that there's a
rogue operation but whatever we know
uh whatever we understand from it uh
we're going to have to recalibrate as
the president
biden has put it this relationship um
and he didn't do that you know i mean
again
there was no real diplomacy going on
uh there was no effort to really end
this war in yemen in an aggressive way
there was no effort to uh to tone down
the ambitions
uh of the crown prince and his ambitions
are are some of them are personal for
his own power and
influence right but many of them are
also for his country
and we needed to be sure that that you
know we can offset the influence that
other countries like china
would begin to have um instead trump was
focusing only on the sale of
military uh hardware yes and
and i i thought that was absolutely
wrong
uh we've been speaking with former u.s
ambassador to saudi arabia
arabia joseph westfall i so appreciate
your time today
and this will certainly be an issue we
will continue discussing
wonderful to be with you david thank you
very much
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman's show you can
check out behind the scenes
pictures memes shots of the studio
shots of what pat does all day very very
concerning to a lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account
at david pakman show i've been very
careful when we've been talking about
george w
bush during the donald trump era not to
participate in the rehabilitation of
george w
bush's image and this is one of the
dangers of not
talking about former presidents which we
discussed a few weeks ago which is
they end up being allowed either
implicitly or explicitly to sort of
rewrite their own history and legacy as
president of the united states
in george w bush's case his legacy is
not taking the 911 threat seriously
enough to start with
more importantly reacting to the 911
attacks by invading
a country that didn't do it the country
of iraq
declaring mission accomplished years
early
staying in a total quagmire of a
situation while hemorrhaging money
and blowing up the deficit all to get us
nothing
while committing war crimes that's a bad
legacy
and i haven't even mentioned the bush
administration's response to hurricane
katrina which is another complete and
total fiasco
and yes at the same time as an
individual
compared to donald trump bush is less
wacky
he's less obviously unhinged he sounds
more reasonable he seems to relate to
people
just on an individual level in a more
normal way than donald trump
but george w bush has partially rehabbed
his image
by becoming friends with michelle obama
and by being friends with ellen
degeneres
and point painting portraits of veterans
and now he's sort of like a friendly
older past
president who just wants everybody to
get along so the point is
i've been careful when we say wow even
george w bush
realizes that this thing trump did or
that thing trump did is terrible
to understand the context of the
horrible legacy of george w bush now
that gets us to this morning
this morning george w bush appeared on
the today show
and he actually laid out a pretty cogent
case against the direction of the modern
republican party
since bush left office through the obama
administration
and during donald trump's one-term
presidency and
he is completely correct he arguably
doesn't even go far enough let's listen
and then we'll talk about it
uh i would describe it as isolationist
protectionist and to a certain extent
nativist
are you disappointed well it's not
exactly my vision
yeah but you know what i'm just an old
guy they put out the pasture so
just a simple painter it's a simple
painter so let's take this in pieces i
mean first of all
is what george w bush is saying correct
it is correct the republican party has
gone
since bush left more fully to the
i don't even know that i'd call it
isolationism and protectionism i'd call
it
nationalism and yes nativism and even
nativism doesn't really go far enough
it's really more
it's almost like a xenophobia that's
very popular in white nationalist
circles it goes beyond nativist so bush
is right and
he probably doesn't go far enough now it
is true
or better said is it true that this is
not
bush's vision for the party as he says
and that it wasn't bush's vision when he
was president
well yes sort of but the truth is more
complicated
it's not the republican party has now
gone nativist xenophobe
and bush wasn't at all that when he was
president of the united states
the reality is that bush's gop
was maybe more indifferent to the
nativism
and they played coy with the nativism
and while they were less
cartoonishly talking about it in the way
trump did
they allowed it and they even had many
people that were part of the
administration that were very much
of that mindset bush personally like is
bush personally a nativist
xenophobe like what he now criticizes
about the republican party
probably not i don't really know but
it's sort of like is trump personally
anti-semitic
we talked before well you know trump has
a jewish daughter by conversion ivanka
and his son-in-law jared kushner
and trump has jewish grandkids and all
this stuff
doesn't really matter trump coalesced
the anti-semites
so his personal view isn't super
relevant to me whatever george w
bush's personal view of the nativist
xenophobic wing of the republican party
is
bush's presidency certainly didn't call
out that wing of the republican party
and it allowed that wing to grow into
what it became
during obama and ultimately led to
donald trump so with all of these issues
it's more complicated than what bush
believes
and it's more nuanced than bush wasn't
at all
on the isolationist nativist gop side
it's more like bush probably calculated
that the republican party was going in
that direction even if it wasn't his
thing
he found a way to placate that wing
without being as cartoonishly welcoming
of it as donald trump
was so what this gets us to is like how
should we react when george w
bush criticizes trump and now is
criticizing the modern republican party
is bush a hero
for calling it out or is he a foe who's
pretending not to have been a part of it
neither life is more complicated it's
not always black and white
the reaction for me is bush was a
disaster
but even bush realizes that the
republican party since him
and under trump is an even bigger
disaster
but he's also partially responsible for
it they all are right i mean
you know what the the right during the
civil rights era
into the vietnam era into reagan
into gingrich and then so on into bush
right i mean
it's all part of what got that party to
what it is today
and you don't have to praise george w
bush to realize that
but you can also recognize the role that
he either implicitly or explicitly or by
negligence had
in getting the party to where it is
today that being said
it's i i i wonder how much of the modern
republican electorate
which is mostly behind donald trump
cares what george w bush says at this
point in time i don't know the answer to
that
remains to be seen very interesting news
on the cannabis front
the house of representatives yesterday
passed a law
which would allow banks to provide
services to cannabis companies
in states where it is legal which is a
significant step
towards removing what is a real barrier
to the development
of this industry nationally as we've
talked about before there has been a
major issue within the cannabis
uh space where even if it is legal
uh and by legal it could be
recreationally legal
recreationally decriminalized but
medically legal and so that's what the
the
the pot shops essentially are selling
whatever the case
if you have to deal in cash because
banks aren't allowed to work with you
that is a major problem it's a security
problem because people know you have so
much cash around it's a problem in a lot
of different ways
lawmakers voted 321 to 101 which means
democrats but also some republicans to
approve the bill
and send it to the senate it is unclear
what is going to happen
in the senate but we know that banks
have been generally not willing to do
business with companies that are in this
business
because they could be running a foul of
federal laws now i'm aware because i
have friends in the industry
um in let's see in arizona
in massachusetts and some other states
they've told me that there are
credit unions that operate only within
one state that seem more willing to work
with cannabis dispensaries and other
businesses
and they feel relatively comfortable
that the government is not going to go
after
them i don't know whether that's
actually true or not
i don't know if that's a false sense of
security but
this is a really important thing now
where you you get to a conflict is
the banking industry wants this and why
do they want it well because it'll be
hugely
profitable and there is a contingent of
people who are sort of stuck
between what is seemingly a rock and a
hard place for them where they want
cannabis legalization
but they really are skeptical of the
banking industry so if the banking
industry wants something
their reflexive reaction is to be
against it
um listen banks are going to make money
with this banks are going to make money
with anything that
is you know whether it's ipos of uh
companies that shouldn't be ipo'ing
holding money for arms deals banks are
going to make money regardless the
question is
do we want to further legitimize this is
an industry so that we can get away from
spending tax money
imprisoning people who either use have
or sell
marijuana and rather collect tax money
from this as a regulated industry and be
able to use that tax money
for public health initiatives for
education for whatever the case may be
i'm of the mindset of i don't want my
tax money going to imprison people
involved in cannabis
i want to see my tax money
uh um bolstered
for lack of a better term by tax money
from a legal and regulated cannabis
industry my position is clear
the positions of of the united states as
a country are moving more and more in
that direction this is a big deal
i don't yet know whether we can expect
it to pass the senate we will see
we have a voicemail number where you can
reach me at 219
to david p i also am launching i
mentioned yesterday that we are new on
this platform called
bitclout you can find me there at
davidpakman.com
bitclout what are going to be my top
20 holders are going to have a system
to directly message me on the platform
and i will write you back so i am
actually establishing a system if you
don't like the voicemail
if you don't like being like some of our
trolls leaving 10 12 voicemails a night
into the void
um follow me on bitcloud
davidpakman.combitclout my top 20
coin holders will have a function to
directly direct message me okay
here is our friend from argentina who
lives in miami unfortunately
she has fallen for an anti-vaccine
talking point take a listen
hi david this is another centennial from
miami right
this is something that i i'm worried
about
and i don't hear anybody talking about
um people who got vaccinated in the
december yes by june may not be
protected anymore because all
they can guarantee is that if the the
protection lasted at least six months
they suppose that maybe it will last
more but
they don't know and
i don't hear about any plan of how to
handle that
so two parts first of all you have to
understand something
when there was an announcement made that
said immunity lasts
for at least six months what they meant
was
we've been following people for six
months and so far
immunity hasn't declined then there was
a seventh month
and it looks like it's now seven months
what they mean by that is
the vaccines being relatively new all we
can say
is they work for the period of time that
people that we've been
putting in trials have been vaccinated
there is no reason to think
that after seven months or eight months
or nine months immunity will go down
the belief among epidemiologists and and
immunologists right now
is that immunity against those original
variants for which the original vaccines
were tuned
likely lasts at least years now if the
virus
changes then the effective the
efficacy will be diminished but by the
fall moderna and pfizer are expecting to
have
boosters tuned to the variant so when
the headline came out
only six months of immunity it was
widely used by anti-vax people to say it
only works for six months no what we
know is it's been six months
and there's no decline in immunity so
far
and we'll look at it after seven and
we'll look at it after eight and we'll
look at it after nine okay that's all
that means
nothing to be worried about for the time
being we have a great bonus show for you
today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com